conservative cancel culture strikes
again Eminem's has decided to do away
with their spokes candies after all
sorts of blowback remember Tucker
Carlson was upset that he wasn't finding
one of the M M's attractive enough it
was very very strange but right Wingers
just furious I don't even know why but
they found the new spokes candies
including I guess one is sort of
androgynous uh very very offensive and
off-putting and so Eminem's has folded
as remember conservatives love to say
it's the left that is canceling this and
canceling that but once again it is the
conservatives that have pushed a
cancellation did you even care about
Eminem's I have to tell you I haven't
had an m m in probably 15 years I did
have a peanut m m eight years ago it was
pretty good it was a yellow one you know
go for for what it's worth that's a joke
by the way folks let me know what you
think about this